at long last the first trailer for matt
reeves to batman has arrived
unleashed the eager masters at the end
of dc fandom on saturday
august 22nd 2020. for a two and a half
minute clip the batman trailer presents
a lot of broad moving parts
but not a lot of answers still there are
a few subtle details that may have
slipped under your radar
as we see commissioner gordon and the
dark knight investigate a murder scene
wallpaper with political newspaper
clippings
one headline in particular stands out
moroni drug bust
while he may not stand tall among the
ranks of the caped crusaders colorful
super powered rogues gallery
mob boss salmaroni has loomed large over
the street level corners of the batman
mythos ever since his first appearance
on the comics page
in 1942 his most distinctive
accomplishment in the canon
splashing district attorney harvey dent
with the acid that would transform him
into two-face
the character has been brought to life a
few times on screen dennis palladino
filled the brief role in batman forever
and the dark knight saw eric roberts
playing maroney as a key figure in dense
downfall
on the small screen meanwhile david
zayez had pied as moroni across eight
episodes of gotham
we don't yet know if style moroni
himself has a part to play in the story
of the batman but his frequent rival
carmine falcone will be played in the
film by john turturro
at the end of the trailer audiences get
a flash of an obscure sort of number
slash code
question mark zero question mark one
take the question marks out of the
sequence
and replace them with the digits that
they look like 2 and you'll get 2021.
this refers to the batman's current
release date of october 1st
2021 but it's also a pretty clear-cut
reference for the film's main villain
the riddler
though the riddler is only briefly
pictured during the trailer we do know
that he's played by paul dano
and disappearance that he'll spend the
duration of the batman psychologically
tormenting the caped crusader
beyond the moroni reference and the
tease of the riddler is going to be the
big bad of the batman
the trailer is thin on substantial
easter eggs and intra cannon references
that said there are a few moments that
caught our attention that may or may not
be meaningful
i'm vengeance first off batman declaring
i am vengeance
could be a call back to a well-loved
line from batman animated series
i am the knight i am
batman perhaps the full quote in the
film includes some of that dialogue as
well
there's also the shot of newspaper
clippings from the gotham gazette
and the gotham times with the words lies
painted over them
those clippings are from stories about
gotham mayor don mitchell jr
who made fictional history by winning a
third mayoral term
in the film jaime lawson will portray a
gotham city mayoral candidate
named bella rael is the surname real are
not so slight hints that she's genuine
and mitchell jr was a phony
and moreover who is don mitchell jr the
only man with that name who has any kind
of association with the batman universe
that we could find is donald o'mitchell
a sound engineer who was nominated for
an academy award for his work in 1995's
batman forever
this is probably a stretch but there
could be something to chew on here
additionally in the scene in which a
group of face paints wearing men square
up against batman there can be spotted a
young man whose face is only half
painted he stands out amongst the crowd
members
who have their whole faces covered in
black and white with various designs
could this boy's inclusion in the batman
be a reference to two-face
finally there's a matter of a mystery
man who pops up on two separate
occasions
in one scene he's simply staring down
the camera with a menacing look on his
face
and in the other he's behind the wheel
of a car that's being pursued the
character is fairly nondescript
and he doesn't really look like anyone
on the batman cast list and the closest
guest we can make would be that he's
oswald as cobble part aka penguin
played by colin farrell that's a big
leap and probably isn't correct but
there's a chance that it might be him
sadly it'll be a fairly long wait for
the unknowns to be resolved the batman
will swoop into cinemas on october 1st
2021 check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about upcoming comic book movies are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one